once you characterized fascism as a
super organism that doesn't care about
the individual cell and if you're not
contributing to the whole then you're
excised and i was curious what's the
difference between that characterization
of fascism and communism
uh communism is tricky because it didn't
really exist right eastern germany
didn't call itself communist it was real
existing socialism communism was a
utopia that uh we aspire to have in many
many generations but it was basically
our promise of the afterlife
it uh that justified the present uh
injustices and uh in accuracies and
mishaps of the system
and
the so that i think that uh there was a
big difference between uh the socialist
country that i lived in and uh fascism
fascism defines the value of the
individual exactly as its contribution
to the group
which means if you are a disabled person
uh you should probably die because your
value is not negative
right if you are a person that is not
identifying as part of the group for
instance if you are jewish and you
have your own community and your own
values and your more cosmopolitan and
bound to a cosmopolitan culture and not
to the idea of a supremacism of uh white
aryans
you are an enemy right you are a dividus
you are
something that lives inside of this
superorganism and you should be removed
by its immune response
and
so this
extreme brutality of fascism that is
destroying everything that is not itself
and that is it doesn't perceive as
valuable
uh is unique to fascism in a way and uh
especially when you do this at an
industrial scale if you do this with
modernist principles there are other
societies of course which
do the same thing as fascism does which
eradicate all the individuals that do
not have
the warrior tribe for instance or that
eradicate everybody who's a little bit
different but they don't do this at
scale
and
the socialism was also a modernist
society
so it worked at scale but it did not
eradicate individuals
for being disabled or being different
there was eugenicism but the eugenicism
existed at the same scale the same
amount and roughly the same time span as
it existed in the west right so in the
1970s uh disabled people were often
sterilized because uh
scientists decided or society decided or
some group within society decided that
they probably shouldn't have offspring
because most of these conditions were
heritable and would create liability in
future generations so the trade-off was
sterilized them and something that we
think now is immoral but by and large
you were not being
eradicated because you were different
eastern germany didn't have gulags as
stalin did
the golex
were i think arguably as bad as the cut
sets of the fascists and they uh but
they targeted people more or less
randomly
like stalin
killed everyone hitler killed those that
he thought were not detrimental to the
state that were enemies of the state and
stalin killed people on a whim
there was no safety in stalinism there
was some safety if you were a proper
member of society in
german fascism and
in eastern germany it was a rather
civilian society the number of political
prisoners
was quite comparable to a number of
western countries
so i would say that in terms of civil
rights and so on it's far inferior to
what existed in the west uh in the
western germany but it's still one of
the most livable countries in the east
and just by being different by being an
artist who didn't play along you didn't
run the risk to get into prison